Preset scan modes are predefined collections of scan settings. They offer a quick way to
adjust how the scan balances speed and coverage. To select a preset scan mode, just navigate
to your sites page, select a site you want to edit, click the details tab and select
edit. We scroll down to our scan settings section, scan configuration is selected by default. Ensure
that you have the use a preset scan mode selected and then we can click one of the available options.
Lightweight is the fastest scan mode with scans capped at 15 minutes in length. It is useful in
situations where you need fast feedback on a target. Fast is intended to give you a general
overview of a site's security posture quickly. Balanced is useful for general purpose scanning.
It is designed to give a good balance between coverage and speed. And finally, Deep is intended
to give you an in-depth look at a site's security posture. The time taken to run a scan using the
Deep configuration depends heavily on the site's size and complexity. Please note you can only select
one preset scan mode for a site. If you want to combine different configurations together on a
single site, you should use a custom configuration instead. We also recommend keeping a consistent scan
configuration for each site that you add. Changing the scan configuration can affect vulnerability trends
over time and cause BIPs with Enterprise Edition to give inaccurate time estimates while scanning.
If you want to scan a site you have already added with a new configuration,
we recommend adding the site again with the new configuration selected. Thank you.